et nous avons maintenant le
saleh
il est
e
d'abord
c'est
avant
et
viola
quel est le lien entre ces entre ces
deux films le chemin c'est toujours
cette figure de la mère qui vous habite
sépare les deux de la mer avant tout
écouter peu de liens si ce n'est le lien
très très fort que j'ai avec avec and
away celui que j'ai eu aussi avec
suzanne qui ont doublé 2-2 laventure
mais les films sont vraiment deux mondes
complètement neuf divisé en fait j'ai
tué ma mère se retrouve à être vraiment
une espèce de fable sur l'adolescence
qui est très anecdotique qui est une
crise d'adolescence alors que momie et
une crise plus existentielles plus vaste
c'est des gens qui s'aiment d'abord ils
sont pas que toute série c'est des gens
qui s'aiment profondément mais qui sont
laissés pour compte dans un système dans
une vie qui les rejette
dofus de par leur nature de par leur
maladie aussi sa maladie à lui aux
offices donc je n'ai pas trop de
parallèles ont fait leur antre justice
actionnaires puis momie parce que y'en a
qui est socialement engagé l'autre est
tellement intime tellement confinés à
l'intérieur d'un même logique de celui
là et on dirait parle de choses beaucoup
plus vaste entrepôt amont à mon sens à
moi bien comment ça c'est passé tout
était pas mal dans le scénario dans les
dialogues au départ puis moi je
travaille toujours la même façon c'est
que je lis le scénario je peux le dire
sans fois avant de commencer à tourner
puis comme xavier c'est un ami on se
voit à toutes les semaines donc on
pouvait en discuter on peut discuter des
dialogues ou si on pourrait pour finn et
certaines choses et puis parce qu'en
fait on crée un personnage avec toute
l'équipe qui est autour de nous quand on
voit le jeans avec l'espèce de macramé
les bottes cbd des décolletés
affriolants alors que elle a quand même
50 ans cette femme là et s'habille comme
une jeune femme de 19 ans a aucun sens
mais ça l'a défini bien aussi elle vous
plaît je les adore c'est une femme
courageuse ou la vie douce mais cite une
femme qui ne s'apitoie jamais c'est une
femme qu une force incroyable mais qui
est une très très grande intelligence
malgré son manque de culture évident
parfois et puis c'est tournure de phrase
terrible mais c'est quelqu'un que je
trouve très très attachant et je laime
vie oui j'avais envie de la défendre
jeudi depuis quelques jours une année
dans la vie de xavier qui vous à 5 de la
mienne à peu près seulement il va
rejeter puits forés tellement ça va vite
et il apprend vite ils absorbent des
informations et désintègre un sancerre
et il va chercher il ne fait que
chercher s'informer apprendre des autres
écouter observer donc c'est très
stimulant qui travaillent avec lui parce
que parce qu on est en même temps on est
sur le qui vive mais on a toujours quand
même foulé sécurité moi je dis sur le
plateau parfois qu'il était comme mon
père tellement même abandonné dans ses
bras je savais qu'il pouvait rien
m'arriver tellement je me sentais aimé
et ça pour moi c'est la plus grande
qualité des réalisateurs ça devrait
toujours être comme ça les réalisateurs
devraient aimer d'amour profond
les acteurs avec qui travaille parce
qu'on donne beaucoup plus en ce temps là
oui je suis très heureux d'être en
compétition officielle pour répondre à
votre première question ensuite où je
trouve l'énergie de faire ce jeu je sais
pas s'écouter c'est ma passion si je ne
sais pas un devoir pour moi de faire un
film je ne sens pas que j'ai besoin de
faire un film à chaque année où à chaque
six mois où c'est une nécessité si c'est
ma manière à moi de m'exprimer
puis je pense que les plateaux de
tournage pour ceux qui les connaissent
que ce soient des acteurs les
réalisateurs des directeurs photo c'est
une ça procure une adrénaline absolument
unique et c'est comme une drogue dure en
fait on en vient jamais vraiment dans le
besoin et pour moi mon rythme de
consommation est élevée j'ai besoin
j'ai besoin de m'exprimer j'ai besoin de
de créer je pense pas vraiment tant de
rapidité ou de le but c'est pas de
pharos tête mène depuis deux 2 devrait
rapidement un rythme
c'est pas ça l'important l'important
c'est de répondre à ses désirs d'une
histoire qu'ils aient besoin d'être
racontée qui semble tout à coup
pertinente
où en est on personnellement je ne veux
pas me poser de limites cause de mon âge
alors quand devrait commencer à raconter
des histoires partager les histoires que
je souhaite compter je crois qu'il y
avait un âge et non peut-être pour
savoir comment conter des histoires mais
il n'y a pas d'âge pour commencer à les
compter deux mois que je suis jeune je
ne vois pas comme quelqu'un de jeune je
suis ni jeune ni vieux j'ai l'impression
simplement que j'essaie d'y ou de faire
les bonnes choses dans l'ordre pour
raconter l'histoire qui me hante d'un
certain point de vue un efi oui si vous
gagnez la palme d'or est ce que le chant
c'est nationale est ce que ce sera la
victoire de québec ou du canada de
lorraine question bien joué alors ce que
nous allons avoir un prix devrions-nous
avoir un prix qu'elle moi je suis
québécois le québec et dans le canada ça
c'est une chose que l'on sait on a
remarqué alors qu'est-ce que soient les
points de vue politiques des uns ou des
autres
j'ai le sentiment que mon film est très
québécois mais que ce serait
certainement une victoire internationale
si j'avais un prix pour moi c'est le jeu
ce que je dis est très personnel mon
fils ne traite pas de ma génération ne
s'associent plus bas doit d'ailleurs
tout cela non film est plutôt un message
extraordinaire à transmettre aux gens de
mon âge de ma génération
un message d'espoir j'aimerais vraiment
pouvoir montrer que mon film est plein
d'espoir